welcome back to another video by simply
learn today we are talking about
something super important for your
online game that is how to do keyword
research with jgb ever wondered why it's
a big deal well we've got you covered in
this video we will break down what
keyword research is why it matters and
most importantly how to do it using chat
jity no confusing stuff just simple
steps just easy steps to boost your
online presence subscribe smash that
like button and let's dive in into the
world of keywords together so now let's
first understand what is keyword
research and why is it important just a
quick info for you if you want to
upskill yourself master digital
marketing skills and land your dream job
or grow in your career then you must
explore simply learns cohort of various
digital marketing programs simply learn
offers various certification and
post-graduate programs in collaboration
with some of the world's leading
universities like spj Purdue and meta
through our courses you will gain
knowledge and work ready expertise in
skills like search engine marketing
strategies for paid campaigns analytics
Roi and evaluation and over a dozen
others that's not all you'll also get
the opportunity to work on multiple
projects and learn from industry experts
working in top TI product companies and
academian from top universities after
completing these courses thousands of
Learners have transitioned into digital
marketing role as a fresher or moved on
to a higher paying job role or profile
if you are passionate about making your
career in this field then make sure to
check out the link in the pin comments
and description box to find digital
marketing programs that fits your
experience and areas of interests so
keyword research is like finding the
words people type into search engines
it's vital for online success picture it
as using the right words to get noticed
on Google by knowing that words people
use you can make your content match what
they're looking for this is crucial
because it means the right people find
your website it's not just about being
at the top of the Google it's about
talking in a way that makes sense to
your audience keyword research is like a
guide helping you know where your
audience is looking it's the key to
making sure your website is easy to find
and has what people are searching for
the significance of research lies in its
ability to line your online presence
with the actual language your audience
uses it ensures that your content
resonates with their queries attracting
a relevant audience interest in your
offerings essentially keyword research
is a strategic tool that not only boosts
search engine rankings but also
establishes a connection between your
content and specific terms your audience
employs making your online presence both
accessible and and meaningful all right
so this was about what is keyword
research and why is it important now
let's understand how to do a keyword
research using chat GPT for that let's
go to google.com so as you can see we
have opened Google Now all we have to do
is to write first of all we'll write
aipm AI PM all right so AI PRM or aipm
for chat gbt you can type now let's open
the first link we'll click on the first
link
so this is basically an extension it is
a Marketplace of prompts they provide
you prompts that you don't have to type
the whole prompt they have pre-made
prompts that you can use all right now
we can click on this add to Chrome
button over here ADD
extension
right so as you can see this is a whole
new outlook of this chat gbt this is
aipm prompt extension so basically they
give you pre-made prompts as you can see
this you used SE optimized content
writer fully SE optimized article
including so there are numerous as we
can see 4 580 prompts so you can choose
accordingly whichever prompt you want
and you can also search over here and
this is topic activity sort by you can
also sort and prompts per page you can
customize it according to yourself so as
you can see here is the topic uh we can
go to topic and we can select so we want
to basically do a keyword research we'll
go to SEO we'll click on SEO after that
in activity we can select this uh
keywords all right now as we can see
there are numerous prompts according to
what we have selected that YouTube SEO
keyword generator SEO optimize your
Google business profile Etc so we can
select as per our choice so so what I
have figured out which is best is this
one keyword analysis I repeat keyword
analysis so as we can see find the table
of best keywords with search volume CPC
paid difficulty Su difficulty so for
those who don't know about uh CPC so uh
CPC or cost per click is a measure in
online advertising that represents the
amount you pay when someone clicks on
your ad it's essentially the cost of
each interaction with your advertisement
higher the CPC values often indicate
more competitive keywords or advertising
spaces and as you can see paid
difficulty is also written so paid
difficulty refers to how challenging it
is to compete for a particular keyword
in paid advertising a higher paid
difficulty score means that it might be
more expensive or competitive to bid for
that keyword in paid search campaigns so
now there is SEO difficulty so SEO
difficulty basically is a measure of how
hard it is to rank organically for a
specific keyword in search engine
results a higher SEO difficulty suggests
that it might be more challenging to
optimize your content to appear higher
in unpaid organic search results for
that keyword it takes into account
factors like competition and the
existing strength of other Pages ranking
for the same keyword so these are the
meanings of these things as we can see
so we have already clicked on this now
now as you can see seed keyword that you
search for so let's say uh I'm searching
for cloud computing let's
say cloud computing and let's click on
this so as we can see they are creating
all these now let's explore keywords
related to cloud computing along with
the respective search volume all right
so as you can see keyword these are the
keywords that we got and these are the
search volumes so we all know what
search volume is the number of searches
and the CPC as we already discussed what
is CPC again if somebody wants to know
about it CPC or cost byli is a measure
in online advertising that represents
the amount you pay when someone clicks
on your ad so these are the amount you
pay when someone clicks on these ads all
right so paid difficulty again it refers
to how challenging it is to compete for
a particular keyword in paid advertising
so this is paid difficulty of of each of
these keywords then SEO difficulty SEO
difficulty is a measure of how hard it
is to rank organically for a specific
keyword in search engine results so
these are the uh Su difficulty so we can
select accordingly and the table index
is a mix of 100 keywords including
longtail LSI so longtail keywords are
also there as you can see we'll discuss
longtail keywords also after this so
this is how you can do keyword research
using chat gbt we'll do one or two more
demos regarding this so let's do another
example so we are going to select
keyword analysis and then we'll have to
put seed keyword remember to select SEO
first of all here we can see SEO and
then in activity you have to select
keywords because we are doing the
keyword research all right now after
selecting this keyword analysis we want
basic we basically want all these things
like search volume CPC PID difficulty s
difficulty so that we can choose the
right keywords accordingly so let's see
here we have to put the seed keyword so
let's say the seed keyword is let's say
devops all right now let's click on
this so they are giving us the keywords
a lot of keywords they usually give
let's explore the keyword analysis for
devops so as you can see high search
volume very high search volume high so
these search volumes regarding these
keywords are shown and the CPC is also
showing
and paid difficulty SEO difficulty as
well so we basically want the SEO
difficulty to minimum like minimum or
like medium so we can search or extract
those keywords accordingly so they have
written this table includes a mix of 100
relevant longtail keywords LSI keywords
and FAQ related to devops it provides
insights into search volume CPC Coster
click PID difficulty and SEO difficulty
to help optimize your content and reach
the target audience effectively so
through this you can select these
keywords and I think if we'll click on
continue it'll keep on going for more
keywords so as you can see longtail
keywords now it is showing so these are
LSI keywords so we will discuss these uh
terms longtail longtail keywords LSI
keywords after some time later in this I
repeat later in this video so this is
how you can simply do a keyword research
using chat GPT again this keyword
research is completely free you have you
don't have to pay a single Buck
regarding this now let's try another
method of doing a keyword research for
that all you have to do is to go to
Google and we'll
type
keywords
everywhere all right so here's the first
link let's click on this this is another
extension install for Chrome we'll click
on install for Chrome now let it open
and now we can click on add to Chrome to
just add this extension in our Chrome
browser as you can see ADD extension so
I think it is added now now all we have
to do is to pin this one all right so
now uh let's go to Chad GPT or let's
open a new
one so as you can see this is keywords
everywhere icon please continue as you
can see clarify explain rewrite so for
that to use this extensions powers or
functionality all we have to do is to
click on on this template button all
right now here the thing is first of all
we'll select choose a category similarly
that we have done previously choose a
category so as you can see copyrighting
marketing SEO social media productivity
professionals we'll select SEO because
we want to do keyword research then in
subcategory we can select keyword
research and because we want to do
keyword research then there's a template
so here we can see first is keyword
strategy so you can click on keyword
strategy if you want to do basically
strategize the keyword so basically I'll
tell you what keyword strategy is
keyword strategy involves planning like
how to use specific words or phrases in
your content to achieve specific goals
like it's about selecting and targeting
keywords that align with your overall
objectives whether it's to boost website
traffic increase conversions or enhance
your online visibility then there is get
search intent for keywords so it I
repeat so it itself tells what it is
like intent understanding search intent
for keywords means grasping the reason
behind someone online search it involves
figuring out what a person is looking
for when they type a particular keyword
into a search engine aligning your
content with users intent ensures that
your information meets their needs
improving the relevance of your content
then here is related keyword generator
so a related keyword generator is a term
or phrase closely connected to the main
keyword your targeting including related
keywords in your content help search
engines understand the content and
relevance of your page it's a way to
capture a broader range of search
queries related to your main topic then
there is longtail keyword so basically a
longtail keyword is a more specific and
detailed phrase usually consisting of
three or more words while these phrases
may have lower search volumes
individually they often attract a more
targeted audience longtail keywords can
be valuable for Niche topics are
generally easier to rank for than
broader more competitive terms so these
are all these things so let's say first
of all I want to search for related
keyword generator and so first of all as
you can see category SEO subcategory
keyword research templates select
accordingly whichever you want I've
explained all these related keyword
generator I want basically when we'll
select related keyword generator this
will come up languages English we want
in English only here is the seed keyword
we'll have to write this is total
keywords how many keywords do we want
we can select accordingly basically I
want 40 itself so this is a prompt
template that automatically gets created
whenever you select a particular
template so let's say if I want to
select keyword strategy so it will
create itself a different kind of prompt
so if I'll select long tail then a
different kind of prompt will be
generated so this is a self-made itself
it will create a prompt all you have to
do is to write a seed keyword over here
so let's say as I said I want related
keyword generator and let's type here
devops all right so total keywords I
want 40 itself now I'll click on execute
template all right so these are the 40
keywords that we wanted so related
keyword generator continues integration
infrastructure as code Dockers
kubernetes shenkin and they're also
telling me the search intent
informational so all of these keywords
are information
so firstly they'll create a table
regarding these keywords after that they
will basically list of same keywords
separated by commas as we can see same
keywords are separated by comma so that
you can easily use them wherever you
want all right so this we have selected
for the what we call Related keyword
generator now let's select another one
let's click on template again we'll go
to related or let's say longtail keyword
generator now we'll put da Ops
again
yes all right so as you can
see I think we'll have to select another
new chat we'll have to create all right
now again we'll go to template longtail
keyword generator devops and let's say
this time we want
50 all right so we'll see whenever we
are doing this editing here also it is
getting edited so let's type 60 then it
will get 60 and whenever we'll type
devops this will also get edited as you
can see so this is a prompt now we'll
click on execute template let's see how
it
goes so these are basically a longtail
keywords as we can see not a single
keyword devops best practices kubernets
deployment genis automation site
reliability engineer Etc basically the
search intent of all these keywords is
like information this one we can see
commercial commercial transactional
deployment so they also show the search
intent and these all are the keywords
separated with commas there are 60 total
keywords now let's do another one we'll
go to template and we'll type let's say
this time we'll type mobile itself now
let's see the keyword strategy for
mobile we have typed mobile as a seat
keyword now execute
template so as you can see category
keyword search and content title and
they're also telling us the title about
as you can see Let It complete this one
then we'll show this so it has generated
the table as you can see please note
that this table includes 24 entries to
maintain Clarity and conciseness if you
need additional keywords or adjustments
feel free to let me know we can click on
this continue to create more but let's
first just see as we can see first of
all types here there is device types
category mobile phone search SE intent
navigational and we can see title is
also there if we'll click on this as we
can see title search intent title
essential guide to choosing the perfect
mobile let's open this essential guide
to choosing the perfect mobile phone
description also is there for your
content so you don't have to do anything
regarding this as you can see explore
our comprehensive guide on selecting an
ideal mobile so description they also
provide a complete description is there
so basically you can just copy paste it
and just copy this and just put it into
an Excel sheet to to just have a look at
it clearly so in Excel sheet you can
easily uh figure out what all keywords
you want to use in your content or your
article so this these two extensions are
important for you if you want to do
keyword research using chat GPT and make
your work easy these two extensions are
completely free so feel free to use them
one is aipm and another one is keywords
everywhere all right guys with that we
have come to the end of this video If
you like this video please give it a
thumbs up I hope it really helped you
all thanks for watching stay safe and
keep learning staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here